The desert is still.
The night seems endless, silent, and at peace…
until it’s pierced by the sound of gunshots
and screams.
Deep in the Sahara, the SCP Foundation is
waging war against a newly discovered enemy.
A squad of foundation agents is retreating,
trying to get away from the ones who massacred
their allies.
They were attempting to eliminate the threat
using conventional means, but their rifles
were no match for the reality bending entities
of the Kingdom of Abaddon.
The retreating agents cover one another as
they make their way back to the extraction
point.
The enemy force advances.
Agents that are caught too close to the sorcerers
of Abaddon disintegrate into thin air.
This is not an enemy they can defeat.
The SCP agents need to get back to base and
relay what they have found to their superiors.
Out of the hundreds of agents sent into the
Sahara that night, only a handful make it
out alive.
They are debriefed by their superiors at the
Foundation who classify the anomalous humanoids
under the highest of threat levels.
The Kingdom of Abaddon is a threat.
The Kingdom of Abaddon must be eliminated.
Reconnaissance done prior to the disastrous
mission had alerted the Foundation to the
presence of anomalies in the region, but they
had no idea how strong the anomalous humanoids
would be.
From data gathered through old reports, it
seemed that the Abaddon humanoids were responsible
for the deaths of no fewer than 75 Foundation
personnel, and had stolen at least 12 different
items from the Foundation.
The leaders of the SCP Foundation tasked research
team Omega-5 with developing a weapon that
would be capable of destroying the Kingdom
of Abaddon once and for all.
The weapon they are researching must be capable
of long range destruction, because the moment
any Foundation agent gets close to the area,
they are vaporized by the reality manipulating
powers of its inhabitants The project is given
the name “Twins of God” and is led by
a Foundation doctor known only by the designation
“O5-1.”
O5-1 is popular in the SCP Foundation, well
known for his in-depth research and charismatic
personality, making him the perfect person
to lead such a project.
And O5-1 recently came across an anomaly that
he believes holds the solution the Foundation
has been looking for to defeat the Kingdom
of Abaddon…
Item-001.And so the Omega-5 team gets to work.
They discover that the anomaly has incredible
powers when put inside a host, which they
refer to as an Item-001 entity, and set up
a series of experiments using different people
to harness its energy The first series of
tests all end in tragedy.
The anomaly causes the entity it inhabits
to become intensely radioactive.
Anyone who gets close to it succumbs to immediate
radiation sickness, and eventually death.
To stop the radiation problems the Omega-5
research group intensifies the containment
procedures.
O5-1 receives reports from the higher ups
that the Kingdom of Abaddon has attacked another
Foundation facility in Sudan.
Long-range defense is needed A.S.A.P.
The administrator puts more pressure on Omega-5,
and especially its leader O5-1, to solve the
problems of Item-001 and develop a weapon
that can save the Foundation.
He stays awake for days on end, working tirelessly
to create a safe and controllable Item-001
entity.
Although there are signs that the weapon will
work, it is still unpredictable.
When Item-001 is initiated, the host entity
becomes paralyzed, suffers severe cerebral
hemorrhaging, and soon a new host is needed
before testing can begin again.
And that’s not the only thing going wrong.
Whenever the anomaly is put into a new host,
sudden and random destruction of on-site structures
and personnel takes place.
O5-1 knows though, that if this power can
be harnessed and controlled in the right way,
that it could be the weapon that the Foundation
needs to wipe out the Kingdom of Abaddon once
and for all.
In order to control Item-001, O5-1 has a mind-kill
switch implanted in its hosts’ brains.
O5-1 can activate the implant to incapacitate
the host and immediately stop the unwanted
destruction.
Countless hosts are terminated by this mind-kill
switch in the early trials conducted by the
Omega-5 team, but progress continues to be
made and eventually a hypothesis is formulated.
Perhaps the disastrous side effects of Item-001
can be offset by spreading the anomaly across
multiple subjects.
They theorize that the immense mental load
of the anomaly can be distributed among several
hosts, thus reducing the toll it takes on
each and giving them the ability to control
its immense power.
But O5-1 and the Omega-5 team need more data,
and for that, they need more bodies.
They consult with the director of Site-17
and it is concluded that the nearby town of
San Marco would be an appropriate place to
get the additional test subjects they require.
On a quiet Sunday morning, Omega-5 along with
support from a squad of armed SCP agents storm
into the San Marcos de la Vida Sterna Church
during the middle of mass.
They gather up a number of the younger congregants
and bring them back to the site where Item-001
is housed.
The researchers quickly ran through their
new supply of test subjects though, and Omega-5
would need to get even more if their research
was to continue.
Instead of going back and forth between the
testing facility and San Marco, O5-1 decides
to move the entire Item-001 operation to the
town itself.
He renames the town, Testing Site-001, and
Omega-5 rounds up 23 of the healthiest subjects
they can find for use in the next series of
research tests.
A few weeks after occupying the town of San
Marco, Omega-5 makes it’s most substantial
progress yet.
Just as they theorized, by spreading out the
anomaly of Item-001 across a specific group
of hosts, they can control its powers.
The tests may have cost the lives of almost
everyone in the town, but the ends certainly
justify the means.
The Kingdom of Abaddon poses an existential
threat to the SCP Foundation after all, and
thanks to this research they will soon have
a weapon capable of bringing them victory.
The Foundation administrator criticizes O5-1’s
methods, but can’t argue with his results.
Unfortunately, O5-1 has a dark secret.
A secret that disturbs even the most hardened
and loyal members of Omega-5.
A secret that has to do with the Item-001
hosts.
The hosts that Omega-5 has made its major
progress with are not the ordinary test subjects
normally used by the Foundation.
No, the test subjects O5-1 makes his breakthrough
with… are children.
Nine of them to be exact, all between four
and eleven years old.
Despite being told specifically by the Foundation
administrator to only test on adults, the
research required O5-1 to break the chain
of command and follow the science down the
path it led.
The children are contained in a reinforced
bunker where only O5-1, and a select few,
have access.
They are technically alive, but are functionally
brain dead.
The group of nine children share a hive mind
that can process information, and more importantly,
can unleash the full potential of the implanted
anomaly, creating and controlling a devastating
power.
But not everyone is thrilled with what they’ve
achieved.
Members of Omega-5 are haunted by the screams
of the children that they’ve forced to be
part of their weapon development program.
They describe their merging with Item-001
as being a process that rips out their souls
and replaces them with something much more
sinister.
In fact all of Omega-5 regret what they have
been a part of and what they’ve done, all
except O5-1.
The nine children can channel unprecedented
amounts of energy from an unknown origin that
Omega-5 hypothesizes comes from an extradimensional
source, which is then used to unbind atoms
at the quantum level.
When the right activation words are spoken,
it appears as though this tremendous power
gives the children the ability to annihilate
anything in the entire universe.
It’s the gun to end all guns.
And only O5-1 has the key to control it.
The nine children work so well within Item-001
that Omega-5 reclassifies it to include the
nine children themselves.
They are not just the entity housing or controlling
Item-001, they permanently become Item-001.
Once Omega-5 has a better understanding of
Item-001, they begin to run tests to find
out the full extent of its abilities.
First they test the distance Item-001 can
reach.
The initial test that Omega-5 carries out
is on a steel rod placed 5 kilometers away.
O5-1 orders the children to destroy the target.
Moments later the phone next to O5-1 begins
to ring.
When he picks it up the observer tasked with
watching the pole is on the other end.
He informs O5-1 that the steel rod has been
completely vaporized.
O5-1 is not satisfied though.
He has another pole set out, this time placed
8,000 kilometers away from the nine children.
O5-1 asks the children to destroy that rod.
Almost immediately, the phone rings again.
The target has been vaporized.
O5-1 smiles.
The next series of tests Omega-5 runs on Item-001
are to determine the maximum size of an object
that can be destroyed.
The tests start out with a steel sphere, 3
meters in diameter, placed 1,000 kilometers
from Item-001.
O5-1 orders the children to destroy the object.
It is instantly vaporized.
O5-1 has seen enough small tests.
It’s time for something big.
So he does something that will later be questioned
by everyone at the SCP Foundation.
He orders the nine children to destroy a Church
of the Broken God worship site in Turkey.
Not long after the destruction order is given
to Item-001, reports begin coming in.
The worship site has been obliterated with
no observable damage to the surrounding area.
Deadly and precise.
O5-1 closes his eyes and takes a deep breath.
He looks as if he is overcome by an immense
spiritual experience.
He opens his eyes, leans over to the children,
and whispers the name of someone.
Later that day, O5-1 finds out that the target
he had named has been vaporized.
The success of Omega-5 and Item-001 is relayed
to the administration of the Foundation.
They are so impressed that they make plans
to use Item-001 to eliminate the Abaddon threat
once and for all.
However, one of the heads of the foundation,
Administrator Williams, has major concerns
about the way O5-1 is running the program.
The updates that O5-1 has been sending have
become less scientific, and more philosophical…
more… spiritual.
Administrator Williams sends a letter to O5-1
reassuring him that he is doing good work,
but once the mission to destroy the Kingdom
of Abaddon is completed, O5-1 will be promoted
to director, and reassigned to the newly constructed
Site-19.
For the good of the Foundation, and maybe
the world, he’ll be permanently moved away
from Item-001.
O5-1’s response is short and to the point,
“I am fine, Administrator.
The project is finished.
We will complete our task when you arrive.”
Administrator Williams arrives at Site-001
a few days later.
He is greeted by O5-1 and the Omega-5 team.
Williams can’t help but notice that O5-1
has a strange look in his eyes.
It is the look of a crazed man who has been
lost in his work, and who has, perhaps, lost
himself.
Williams puts the thought away though and
walks with O5-1 and his accompanying agents
to the viewing area where the powers of Item-001
will be demonstrated.
Administrator Williams and the other agents
watch from a protected viewing room as O5-1
enters the chamber of his new super weapon.
It’s time to see if their weapon that has
had so much time, effort, sweat, tears, and
especially blood poured into it, will have
been worth it.
Everyone watches as O5-1 leans over and says
the name of the Abaddon Citadel to the nine
children.
All at once, they start to glow.
No one observing can see what has happened
in the far off Kingdom, but they know something
big has happened.
The administrator is thrilled, but notices
something.
O5-1 hesitated a moment while leaning over
the children before standing back up.
Did he whisper something else to them?
And then Administrator Williams vaporizes,
pulled apart at an atomic level before he
has the chance to scream.
What’s going on?
The agents standing next to where Administrator
Williams previously existed begin to yell
and pull out their guns.
They burst through the door of the observation
room and run down the hallway towards where
O5-1 and the nine children are located.
The armed agents rush into the room, but O5-1
is gone.
The nine children are still.
Over the next few weeks O5-1 is reported to
be seen several times by SCP agents.
However, no one is able to catch him, and
it appears as though other members of the
SCP Foundation have also gone AWOL as well,
perhaps joining him on the run.
It is unclear what his plan is, but reports
from the reconnaissance team sent into the
Sahara make it obvious what the result of
his first command to the children was.
There isn’t a single humanoid or building
left in the Kingdom of Abaddon.
But even with this victory, the highest levels
of the SCP Foundation have an ominous thought
lurking in the back of their minds.
Where did O5-1 go, and what is he planning
to do next?
Following the improper use of Item-001 leading
to the untimely death of a high ranking Foundation
Staff member, the weapon was deemed too dangerous
and containment procedures were implemented.
Due to the high amount of radiation they were
found to emit, the nine children were placed
into lead lined bags and buried under 50 meters
of concrete beneath the church of San Marcos
de la Vida Eterna.
Though all of the children continue to be
functionally braindead, they still display
signs of life despite their containment, and
by order of the Overseer Council, have been
classified as a Thaumiel entity.
Now go watch SCP-5000 - The Suit or SCP-1730
- What Happened at Site-13 for more epic tales
from the SCP archives.